visitors to nürnberg often can be seen
taking photos and there's certainly no
shortage of worthy subjects to capture
on camera we begin with the city's most
famous landmark the Kaiser Borg or
Imperial Castle the German kaisers
rarely stayed here for long but they did
come here often using the occasion to
hold lively parties and every newly
elected Kaiser held his first Imperial
diet here in the city below omage is
still paid to the Kaiser the Church of
Our Lady features a glockenspiel every
day at noon seven electoral princes
filed past the Holy Roman Emperor
Charles the 4th it's another popular
tourist attraction
[Music]
the medieval sites are all located in
the center of the city and so close
together that they can easily be reached
on foot the bridges over the pigness
River are another popular motif the
hangman's bridge is an original wooden
construction from the Middle Ages
[Music]
90% of nürnberg was destroyed during the
Second World War but in many areas it's
still possible to get a sense of how the
city must have looked for example the 22
houses of the vice Gera Gaza or Tanner's
Lane have been completely preserved the
street was once home to medieval
craftsmen but those who had really made
it opted for something more grand this
Renaissance mansion was home to the
two-car family they earned their wealth
from trading in spices nürnberg number
one source of income at the time the
toker mansion with its grand staterooms
and banqueting-hall
is now a museum open to the public
[Music]
so all-in-all Nurenberg is definitely a
city with medieval appeal
[Music]